president zielinski who has military
experience who can join the defense of
Ukraine has to come to the military
offices of the ministry of internal
affairs
keep yourself updated on the information
we have wounded soldiers
in hospitals that require blood
donations please join and donate your
blood
We Carry Out serious work on the defense
and every Enterprise every business
person
needs to help please look after your
workers your employees
all people should have all the necessary
facilities and goods
the bank system of Ukraine
has scored the resources to protect this
state
to protect the interests
of Ukrainian Nationals
I'm grateful to all the politicians who
support Ukraine and defend our
sovereignty we are all Ukrainian
citizens
and we are now defending our country
yeah and we will fight for our country
and we will support our country each in
the squares of each town
armed forces are ready to protect our
country
within the territorial defense
this morning dear citizens
this morning became a history it's a
different history to our country and to
Russia we broke up diplomatic relations
with Russia
Ukraine is now defending itself we will
not give up our independence
Independence and the right to live in
our own country
is the highest value
they attacked our country early in the
morning just like fascist Germany did
during the second World War
today our two countries are on different
sides of the history Russian Federation
is on the side of the evil but
Russian Nationals
will decide today
what path they will take what side they
will want to be at
those who have some conscience and
conscientiousness they should stand
against the war
we against Ukraine
I also want to address
to the
Ukrainian citizens who speak Russian I
know that I know this information is not
allowed on your um channels
um they blocked it it's this evil desire
to destroy a Ukrainian Nation you can't
block it you can't block history that's
why dear Ukrainian citizens
dear ukrainians
those who have relatives in Russia I'm
sure you have them
friends John list in Russia please
appeal to them talk to them tell them
what's happening and then Russia will
know what is actually happening thank
you very much
every hour we will come out and speak to
you
we'll talk to our people to our society
and From This Moment
this is all our armed army glory to
Ukraine